und wir machen einen harten schnitt und
wechseln an diesem so wichtigen
nachrichten tag ins kanzleramt zum
corona gipfel der aktuell auf der
zielgeraden ist dort sitzen sie also
heute via video schalte wieder zusammen
die ministerpräsidenten und die
bundesregierung und beraten über die
korona regeln schon im vorfeld hieß es
die werden erst mal nicht verschärft
aber die werden auch erstmal nicht
gelockert das war die erste nachricht
schon vor dem corona gipfel hier sehen
wir sie dann sitzen und miteinander
sprechen chef der veranstaltung ist
hendrik wüst der chef der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz also der
nordrhein-westfälische ministerpräsident
und sie haben gerade marco buschmann den
justizminister gesehen und sehen hier
die bilder der ankünfte am vormittag
dort hervor fahrten am kanzleramt das
ist wer kommt er aus dem auto raus
schauen wir auf den kanzler der
wahrscheinlich schon drin ist zu diesem
zeitpunkt und dort eben berät sie haben
gerade gesehen mit henry briest
nordrhein westfalens ministerpräsident
bayerns ministerpräsident zugeschaltet
aus dem homeoffice sozusagen ein aus
seiner staatskanzlei und darüber
sprechen wir hier im studio mit
bildpolitik chef jan schäfer bei halo es
sich herzlich der gipfel auf der
zielgraden habe ich gerade gesagt oder
gerade abgepfiffen also es ist jetzt
sind die letzten minuten und anders als
es in den gipfeln davor war die letzten
12 die wir ja hier auch live mit
begleitet haben gab es heute auch
ordentlich zoff wir sehen es auch hinter
dir eingeblendet einige
ministerpräsidenten sind ganz kräftig
auf den bundesgesundheitsminister
losgegangen und zwar so heftig dass der
sich am ende sogar entschuldigt hat also
das ist die nachricht dieses corona
gipfels es wurde heute unangenehm für
karl lauterbach für den neuen
bundesgesundheitsminister was genau ist
der hintergrund vermutlich spielt das
robert koch institut eine entscheidende
rolle also diese kurzfristige änderung
des genesenen status ja es gibt zwei
kernpunkte du hast einen erwähnt das
robert koch institut und diese nacht und
nebelaktion muss man fast sagen der
innerhalb von wenigen stunden der
genesenen status einfach von sechs
monaten auf drei monate verkürzt wo das
hat vielen ministerpräsident nicht
geschmeckt unter anderem dem hessischen
ministerpräsidenten volker bouffier der
da lautstark auf karl lauterbach
losgegangen ist und auch gesagt hat das
hat jetzt viel vertrauen die kostet
diese maßnahme weil den
ministerpräsidenten eigentlich etwas
anderes gesagt worden war von karl
lauterbach und der zweite punkt und dem
ist heute auch gar kein bisschen streit
natürlich um das ganze thema test mangel
pcr-test mangeln auch da karl lauterbach
in der bredouille am ende musste er sich
sogar entschuldigung hat gesagt ja klar
seine kommunikationsstrategie das ist
richtig die war da jetzt nicht in
ordnung er sagt aber auch hätte er es
anders gewusst dann hätte er die
ministerpräsidenten anders informiert es
ist nicht ganz klar wer da nun richtig
liegt wer falsch nie ganz klar ist die
ministerpräsidenten waren heute sei es
gab eine abreibung für den gesundheits
also heftiger angriffe gegen karl
lauterbach das ist einer der einstecken
kann das haben wir hier bei bild live
auch wieder immer wieder erlebt das ist
einer der sich der diskussion stellt und
dann eben auch zurück schießt wenn es
nötig ist geht der geschlechter heute
aus der sitzung raus als geprügelter
hund sozusagen also ganz klar ist beim
letzten corona gibt anfang des jahres am
17 januar da gab es einen eindeutigen
sieger das war die ampel das war in form
von olaf scholz und karl lauterbach auch
diese beiden personen so und die es die
unionsgeführten länder waren er deutlich
die unterlegenen gerade in eine persona
auch von henrik wüst dem
nrw-ministerpräsidenten heute anderes
spiel heute ganz klar der sieg nach
jetzigem stand zumindest leicht bei den
unionsgeführten bundesländern volker
bouffier den auftakt gemacht markus
söder und wenn sich ein
gesundheitsminister entschuldigt sprich
das einerseits für ihn weil er größe
zeigt das zeigt aber auch dass er
ziemlich unter druck gewesen ist und
interessant noch dass manuela schwesig
die ministerpräsidenten von mecklenburg
vorpommern karl lauterbach sogar zu
hilfe gesprungen ist beide sind ja in
der spd und gesagt hat man sollte jetzt
diese entschuldigung annehmen und als
dann markus söder noch mal nachhaken
wollte und noch mal nachlegen wollte
ging sogar olaf scholz dazwischen und
sagte so jetzt müsste das ganze hier mal
beendet werden müsse weiterkommen im
programm also deutlich in der defensive
heute die spd eher vorne mal dabei die
union hatte man sich verabredet unter
den unions ministerpräsident heute
richtig den in die zange zu nehmen den
karl lauterbach ganz offenbar also wir
haben das ja in den letzten wochen auch
immer wieder erlebt die union ist jetzt
in einer anderen situation sie muss
jetzt
als opposition in gewisser weise auch
angreifen die regierung stellen das hat
beim letzten kodak finde ich richtig
geklappt aber es gab immer wieder diese
versuche auch zu sagen die regierung
müsste jetzt ein vorschlag
beispielsweise bei der impfpflicht
vorlegen das hatte beim letzten mal olaf
scholz einfach so abtropfen lassen aber
erkennbar ist die union in der
opposition versucht die regierung zu
stellen ganz interessant ist ja auch
dass es unions-ministerpräsidenten waren
gerade in form auch von markus söder die
diesmal nicht gesagt haben weiter
verschärfen sondern die eigentlich das
gegenteil gesagt haben nämlich wir
müssen gucken dass wir eine öffnung
perspektive kommt dass wir eher wieder
öffnen den menschen den firmen eine
chance geben wieder aufzumachen das war
ja wir erinnern uns unter angela merkel
eigentlich genau andersherum darüber
wollen wir gleich sprechen mit unser
bild reporterin hat ja es war dort am
kanzleramt sie sehen oben rechts schon
das bild aus dem kanzleramt also das
kennen sie aus den letzten jahren aus
den letzten monaten erwarten wir dass
die protagonisten platz nehmen also vor
allen dingen der kanzler olaf scholz und
daneben auch ein trick wüst über den wir
gerade hier gesprochen haben also das
nehmen wir mit von jan schäfer das war
eine grill stunde sozusagen für karl
lauterbach der ist da ordentlich unter
druck geraten hessens ministerpräsident
volker bouffier kritisiert dieser mann
habe mit seinem handeln in den
vergangenen tagen vertrauen gekostet in
ganz deutschland das ist schon heftiger
angriff gegen karl lauterbach aber
wichtig ist was hier bei rauskommt in
diesem papier das ist die
beschlussvorlage also das papier vor dem
gipfel was wird er heute beschlossen an
corinna regeln was ändert dass
möglicherweise auch in ihrem alltag in
ihrem corona alltag darüber wollen wir
sprechen mit nadja aswad vor dem
kanzleramt größer durch nadja
jan hat gerade live
naja als effektive öffnung perspektive
ja mensch das klingt erstmal danach dass
das ganz positiv klingt aber bedeutet ja
auch naja gut eine perspektive die
langsam erarbeiten da kommt erst mal
noch nichts mit lockerungen richtig
genauso das habt ihr habt ihr ganz
richtig interpretiert schon also man
kann sich im prinzip darauf einstellen
dass es erstmal so bleibt wie es ist es
wird damit gerechnet dass die große
omikron welle erst in ungefähr vier
wochen über uns alle ein bericht
deswegen bis jetzt keine öffnungs
perspektiven da gab es ja gestern noch
einen leichten hoffnungsschimmer
der mann hat versucht sich auf
großveranstaltungen zu einigen das hat
sich auch heute durch den vormittag
gezogen als die länderchefs ohne das
bundeskanzleramt getagt haben dann hat
man tatsächlich versucht eine
einheitliche gangart zu finden wie will
man umgehen mit großveranstaltungen das
hat dann aber am ende doch nicht
geklappt also man konnte sich nicht
darauf einigen welche regeln man da
gelten lassen möchte und wir haben auch
gehört dass die konferenz der
ministerpräsidenten ohne das kanzleramt
wo noch kontroverser gewesen sein soll
als die eigentliche pkw da haben wir ja
schon gehört wurde karl lauterbach unter
feuer genommen aber im vorfeld der mpk
ist nur die mps unter sich gesprochen
haben gab es noch mehr zocker hat unter
anderem sachsens mp michael kretschmer
franziska giffey angegriffen vollkommen
aus dem nichts haben wir gehört dann hat
sich darüber beschwert dass ja in berlin
überhaupt gar nichts läuft man hat dann
offenbar nicht verstanden worum es
eigentlich konkret gegen was konkret
sein vorwurf aber es war wohl mächtig
zoff in der luft und sehr gepfeffert und
als das kanzleramt sich dann
zugeschaltet hat ist das zivilisierter
geworden aber trotzdem noch sehr
kontrovers hören wir also es gab es oft
der lauterbacher so unter druck geraten
und es gibt erst mal keine wesentlichen
lockerungen außer dass über wieder
zuschauer bei großveranstaltungen
gesprochen wird ehrlich gesagt gibt es
im alltag jedoch noch größere probleme
riesenärger moment diesen ärgernis
dieser pcr-test mangel lange schlangen
in ganz deutschland wo man sich die
beine in den bauch steht und dann
natürlich auch die quarantäne regeln die
das leben so schwer machen vor allen
dingen für schüler und schülerinnen und
für kita kinder so viele raus so viele
kitas und klassen wieder geschlossen
gibt's da lösungen heute
tatsächlich nicht man hat jetzt zuletzt
über wirtschaftshilfen diskutiert und
gerade bringt mein handy jetzt gerade in
diesen minuten hat die mpk aufgehört
also insofern sehen wir wahrscheinlich
gleich die pressekonferenz und den
bundeskanzler mal gucken was die dann zu
verkünden haben
hörst du schon was über den zeitplan
wird das eine abendveranstaltung ist ja
mittlerweile längst dunkel geworden vom
kanzleramt oder rechnest du damit dass
wir hier gleich ja diepresse.com
verleben
also ich bekomme aus mehreren quellen
tatsächlich die mpk ist jetzt zu ende
das heißt ich rechne damit dass wir
gleich ins kanzleramt schalten könnt und
dann hört was bundeskanzler stolz zu
sagen hat tatsächlich unklar ist der tag
war sehr energiegeladen und sehr streit
und konflikte geladen und am ende ändert
sich eigentlich nicht wirklich was für
die leute dann kann bild reporterin
nadja aswad vor dem kanzleramt also das
schon mal die erste nachricht nach den
inhalten dass es gleich losgeht mit der
pressekonferenz dass der korona gipfel
dort im kanzleramt diese video schalte
mit dem ministerpräsidenten gerade zu
ende gegangen ist jan ich habe die
probleme pcr tests und auch quarantäne
schon angesprochen während wir hier
sprechen kommt gerade die meldung von
uns von der schule hier das schon wieder
der unterricht dort wahrscheinlich
ausgesetzt wird berlin auch gleichzeitig
sagt am nachmittag heute die
präsenzpflicht in berlin wird ausgesetzt
das heißt das sind keine guten hier sind
wir noch mal die entsprechende
mitteilung hier von der
bildungssenatorin aus berlin also der
präsenzunterricht die präsenzpflicht
ausgesetzt das sind alles keine guten
nachrichten für schüler und schülerinnen
auch nicht für eltern das alles passiert
und dafür gibt es offenbar aktuell keine
lösung das ist ja eher einem lock down
als eine lockerung also ich glaube wir
hatten es heute mit einem
corona gipfel der banalen
selbstverständlichkeiten zu tun wenn man
auch sich die beschlussvorlage die jetzt
ja mehr oder weniger abgearbeitet wurden
anschaut dann stehen da punkte drin das
also karl lauterbach aufgefordert wird
für mehr pcr tests zu sorgen ja was denn
sonst kann man ja eigentlich nur fragen
es geht darum die kontakt nachverfolgung
wieder zu verbessern wir wissen von ganz
vielen gesundheitsämtern die überlastet
sind und die kontakte wer hat jetzt wen
infiziert nicht nachverfolgt das soll
jetzt verbessert werden ja was denn
sonst möchte man fragen also das waren
viele viele banalitäten in einer
natürlich schwierigen lage ohne frage
aber worauf man sich eigentlich nicht
geeinigt hat ist zum beispiel eine
öffnung strategie eine eröffnungs
perspektive da heißt es bisher das soll
in den nächsten zwei drei wochen
erarbeitet werden ja ich hätte gedacht
das hätte man erarbeitet und kommt heute
zu einem punkt um dann sagen zu können
wie wollen wir denn genau machen also
auch dieser gipfel hat getagt
hat vieles verschoben der nächste findet
mutmaßlich am 16 februar statt da werden
wir hoffentlich dann etwas schlauer sein
aber ganz klar ist heute ist hier nichts
entschieden wurden heute saß man einfach
zusammen hat ein bisschen geredet es gab
es oft natürlich aber es ging am ende
hier um banalitäten belanglosigkeiten es
ist ganz klar wenn es zu wenig test gibt
muss es mehr tests geben aber dafür
brauche ich eigentlich kein corona
gipfel jetzt wird priorisiert bei den
pcr tests das heißt nicht mehr alle
sollen dann tatsächlich pcr-test
pflichtig sein genauso ist es geht um
wir sind einer in einer situation sagt
der bundesgesundheitsminister ja auch in
der es offenbar nicht genügend pcr tests
gibt wo die labore auch überlastet sind
genau jetzt geht es vor allem darum das
so genannte variable gruppen bei einem
positiven normalen corona test dann das
anrecht auf einen pcr tests haben ganz
genau und auch andere gruppen
beispielsweise natürlich pflegepersonal
ärzte die also sehr viel in kontakt mit
corona patienten auch sind die bekommen
einen pcr-test und die anderen müssen
dann bei einem positiven aller gentest
normalen corona test einen zweiten
machen bekommen diesen pcr-test erstmal
nicht aber das soll jetzt nach diesem
gipfel ja auch wie gesagt verändert wie
eine hoffnung dass es künftig wieder
mehr pcr tests gibt das heißt schon dann
muss man zu hause bleiben bei einem
positiven schnelltests zumindest wenn
dann ein zweiter positiver schnelltest
erfolgt das mögen einige arbeitnehmer
einige angestellten und auch schüler und
schülerinnen mit grausen sehen das wird
ja zu noch mehr quarantäne fällen führen
na gut das ist ja genau der punkt um den
es geht also dass dieser zweite nicht
pcr-test dann quasi wie ein pcr test
eingesetzt werden soll ja thema
quarantäne ärgernis für ganz ganz viele
weil eben so viele aktuellen quarantäne
müssen weil irgendjemand in der klasse
irgendjemand bei der arbeit eben positiv
getestet wurde da gibt es keine abhilfe
aktuell da gab es heute keine stimmen
die gesagt haben wünscht dass es da die
regeln so wie in anderen ländern auch
mal ordentlich locker nach unserem stand
gab es das bisher nicht alles bleibt
bisher so es sei denn es gibt gleich
noch eine überraschung und wir hören da
etwas neues in der pressekonferenz nach
unserem stand bleibt alles so und wir
wissen ja wer gepustet ist der muss
eigentlich erstmal dann nicht groß in
quarantäne wenn er kontakt hatte
beispielsweise was ein wichtiger punkt
ist der letzte woche aufs tableau kamen
und der heute aber auch nicht besprochen
wurde dass wir wichtig gewesen ist die
frage inwieweit müssen eigentlich erst
oder einmal und zweimal geimpft
wenn sie in quarantäne müssen eigentlich
bekommen die lohnfortzahlung oder
bekommen sie die nicht das betrifft
millionen von arbeitnehmern dass ein
unsicherheitsfaktor für millionen von
arbeitnehmern heute bisher kein
sterbenswörtchen dazu das heißt woran
liegt das aktuell wer führten diesen
corona gipfel diese mpk sie eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz es gibt
einen chef der ministerpräsidenten das
ist seit oktober oder etwas später muss
man sagen henrik wüst seit oktober führt
nordrhein westfalen aber zunächst war
armin laschet chef der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz jetzt ist
es henrik wüst und natürlich ist am ende
das kanzleramt federführend olaf scholz
ist dann ja der gastgeber des ganzen
aber das sind die beiden führenden köpfe
olaf scholz als bundeskanzler er kommt
von der spd und hendrik wüst als chef
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz er
kommt von der cdu